barack obama gets wildly partisan at a
memorial for congressman
john lewis media members exploit herman
cain's death to slam president trump
and trump struggles with the
consequences of his insane threat to
delay the election i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn
dot com slash ben well there's one
general rule when somebody who is
prominent eyes and that is you kind of
hold your fire at least for
you know the next 30 seconds and
typically you don't use their memorials
particularly if they are very large
figures you don't use their memorials as
sort of launching points
for politics this has been a rule that i
would say republicans have been better
at applying than democrats in the recent
past whenever a major democrat dies or
whenever there's a bad event
that results in death and the democrat
speaks at the memorial
it very often turns into a political
rally so it's nothing new that that's
what happened
yesterday with regard to the memorial
for congressman john lewis
there's precedent for this when senator
paul wallstone died in a plane crash
back in the 2000s
the democratic party held a full out
political rally stumping for progressive
policy
when there was a mass shooting in
arizona that was the same shooting that
injured gabby giffords the congresswoman
barack obama deployed himself to arizona
where he proceeded to rant and rave
about gun control and talk about the
evils of his republican opponent so it
really was nothing new what happened at
the john lewis memorial that doesn't
make it any better and it does
demonstrate the utter classlessness
of a lot of people in our politics who
tend to use death as a rationale
for jumping into debate over over
politics
purely speaking now listen i understand
the temptation i'm on twitter too i get
it
you know and i can't say that i've been
blameless in this my entire twitter
history i will say that over the past
few years one of the things i've learned
is the day somebody dies just shut it
it says the day somebody dies let it go
the the the day of a memorial
what you want to talk about is the stuff
that unified about the person you don't
want to talk about the stuff that was
not unifying about the person there's
plenty of time
for that later we can tell the
difference in the class level of our
various presidents over the course of
history and
kind of why donald trump is president
thanks to the reactions yesterday at the
john lewis memorial so there are several
presidents who spoke
at the memorial for congressman louis
lewis of course was a disciple of martin
luther king jr
he was one of the leaders of the civil
rights movement
he famously was one of the people who
attempted to desegregate lunch counters
by peacefully protesting at lunch
counters he helped lead the mark of
selma
you real hero in his younger days and
then served in congress
obviously in many ways heroically and
this is somebody with whom i disagreed
on politics i would say a lot a lot but
you still try to look for the good in
people and not only the good i mean this
is somebody who really did contribute to
making the country a better place over
the course of his life
well george w bush gave a speech
yesterday and it was amusing to watch
members of the media suddenly recognize
that george w bush was a good person
and jonathan k part at the washington
post is like well george told me what a
wonderful man what an incredible man
what a great speech yeah five minutes
ago you all were saying that george w
bush was the worst scourge of the earth
and frankly i look forward to the time
four years from now or eight years from
now whenever
trump is no longer in office and another
republican is running when democrats
turn around and talk about what a
bipartisan guy
donald trump was because that's how how
it always works ronald reagan was the
worst
until george h.w bush was running at
which point reagan became the good
republican
then george h.w bush was the worst until
bob dole was running
at which point george h.w bush became a
wonderful wonderful man
then bob dole was bad all the way up
till george w bush was running
and the same pattern holds true so there
will be a great irony to the fact you
watch
four years from now eight years from now
there will be a lot of talk about even
donald trump didn't do
this even donald trump wasn't his donald
trump i mean that was a a bipartisan
messenger for the ages anyway george w
bush gives a speech yesterday very
classy speech at the john lewis memorial
a couple notes about the john lewis
memorial generally first of all
looked like a generally beautiful event
also there there is a gap between how
elites in this country are viewed with
regard to attending public
events at this time and people who are
quote unquote the little people and if
you're
a a quote-unquote little person in
america meaning a non-politician a
non-prominent person in america
and you look at the large-scale memorial
event for john lewis and you think to
yourself hold up
my mom died in the hospital alone and we
still haven't been able to hold a
memorial
why do we get to do this for john lewis
that is not an unfair question
it really isn't when you look at andrew
cuomo in new york saying that if you go
to georgia and you come back from
georgia you have to quarantine for 14
days
and then you look at a wide variety of
people from dc and new york going to
john lewis's memorial do you think any
of them are going to quarantine
when they get back to dc or new york of
course not even though
the memorial service was held in georgia
anyway george w bush's speech was quite
good here was george w bush talking
about
john lewis and how he made the country a
better place
we the people including congressmen and
presidents
can have differing views on how to
perfect our union
while sharing the conviction that our
nation however flawed
is at heart a good and noble one
we live in a better and nobler country
today because of john lewis
and his abiding faith in the power of
god
in the power of democracy and in the
power of love
to lift us all to a higher ground
yeah i mean that's that's wonderful it's
a wonderful thing to say and that is why
you saw so many people paying tribute to
bush now remember
bush was the villain until five seconds
ago as soon as a republican
is not in power the republican becomes
you know just a normal nice guy that we
all hang out with when he's in power
he's super duper duper evil well bill
clinton also spoke
at the memorial event and bill clinton
was slightly more political than bush he
talked about
sort of the continuing mission of john
lewis john lewis had a posthumous
obituary that was published in the
washington post
in which he talked about the continuing
mission and he name-checked a bunch of
people who are supposedly victims of the
police
including a couple people like ray shard
brooks who was not a victim of the
police in any case
clinton invoked sort of john lewis's
politics in a vague sense going forward
which
again if you're vague about it is not
unfair he also
invoked the differences between stokely
carmichael and john lewis stokely
carmichael of course
was uh significantly more an advocate of
violence than john lewis who's very much
into non-violence
bill clinton did this he got ripped up
and down for it
just three years later he lost the
leadership of
snick to stokely carmichael he showed as
a young man
[Music]
there are some things that you cannot do
to hang on to a position because if you
do them you won't be who you
are anymore there were two or three
years there where
the movement went a little bit
too far towards stokely but
in the end john lewis prevailed okay and
that's actually a good point but people
on the left were very angry at bill
clinton for having said this
because right now we're seeing violence
in our streets and that's bill clinton
basically slapping at the violence in
the streets that's him saying that john
lewis would not have been in favor of
the violence in the streets they've been
seeing the rioting
and the looting which he is right about
he got slapped by a columnist over at
the root for this saying
why are you invoking stokely carmichael
here again there's a rationale for it
but the real politicization was reserved
for barack obama who got extraordinarily
political and it is a reminder of why
donald trump is president because barack
obama is a much more elegant speaker
he's a much more subtle person than
donald trump donald trump is just the
very loud and
he's the checkered suit version of
barack obama right barack obama was a
used car salesman in a really night suit
and donald trump has used car salesmen
in a checkered plate
that is the main difference between them
because barack obama is purely political
he is a political animal he will say
purely openly political things that are
bizarre
and over the top and really kind of
crazy
and he'll do it at a memorial service
and then the media will praise him as a
statesman and donald trump is like okay
just get rid of the statesman and i'll
just say all this stuff
out loud and i'll say the quiet part out
loud the truth is
that barack obama got all the plaudits
for being a
master of subtlety he never was
particularly subtle right he was he's
more subtle than trump
but that's because literally all the
things are more subtle than trump
all trump is is you strip off the veneer
of barack obama
and the political the overt
politicization of
all the things they're kind of the same
they're kind of saying we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that you are overspending
on your wireless bill
you really are now i know you're
thinking yourself but but i use my
cell phone all the time you do use your
cell phone all the time but if you're
not using unlimited data
you are really really overpaying who is
your wireless provider by the way a t
verizon t-mobile what if i told you that
pure talk usa
uses the exact same network as one of
those carriers the same towers the same
exact coverage but literally costs you
half
how does it become so affordable well
there are no retail stores so low
overhead you're not funding their
billion dollar ad campaigns and
you're only paying for the data you need
so no contract no excessive fees you'll
enjoy unlimited talk text and two gigs
of data all for just 20 bucks a month
that is right the average person is
saving 400 bucks a year on their
wireless bill so
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do
you get this amazing deal and save 50
off your first month again that is pound
250 pound 250
say keyword ben shapiro and you're
saving 50 bucks off
on your cell phone bill which is great
again you're not using the unlimited
data you're just paying for it so why
not get a better deal
right now with the same coverage you'd
be getting from the big huge companies
grab that mobile phone dial pal 250 say
ben shapiro and get started right now
say 50
off at your first month as well okay so
barack obama an overtly political animal
so barack obama gets up at john lewis's
memorial
and in the process he slams federal
agents and compares them to george
wallace
yeah i'm sorry this is incredibly ugly
stuff the idea that federal agents today
are the same as jim crow bull connor
racist police officers in 1960 selma
is patently insane it's crazy okay what
you're watching in america's major
cities where federal agents are
defending
federal property from mostly white
rioters and looters by the way who are
attempting to
set buildings on fire that's nuts but
this is
barack obama was a demagogue and never
never forget the barack obama demagogue
i know that we're supposed to pretend
that donald trump is the first demagogue
in american history
i know we're supposed to pretend that
all of political time space began
with the big bang that was donald trump
it is not true donald trump was a direct
response
to the to the malicious manipulation
of barack obama barack obama was a
terrible president he was a terrible
divisive president
and the media gaslet you about that the
media pretended that he was a unifying
force
the media would cherry-pick his speeches
the parts are going to talk about we're
not a red america or blue america
or united states of america and then
they'd ignore all the crap where he
suggested that we absolutely were not
united that racism is in america's dna
they would ignore the powers where he
basically went and nodded at rioting in
ferguson in baltimore
they just ignore that i mean what you're
about to hear him say again
at the memorial for a dead man right a
man who united the country around
principles
that at the time were extraordinarily
controversial but became the culture
right this was the counter culture it
became the culture
thank god a culture of racial tolerance
and racial
and racial understanding and a belief in
martin luther king's dream
and here's barack obama pretending
there's no difference between bull
connor police officers
shooting fire hoses at john lewis in
and federal officers attempting to fight
rioting and looting in america's major
cities in 2020 60 years later
and this is demagoguery of the highest
order here's barack obama being a
demagogue
well connor may be gone but today
we witness with our own eyes police
officers kneeling on the necks
of black americans george wallace may be
gone
but we can witness our federal
government
sending agents to use tear gas and
batons
against peaceful demonstrators okay
this is this is such demo it truly is
demagoguery
it it is unrelated to reality even the
notion
that that bull connor is gone but derek
shalvin still exists there is no
evidence at this point that derek
schalvin
knelt on george floyd's neck out of
racial animus there isn't
okay that evidence may come but that
evidence does not exist
it's there's not a single person who
agrees that what derek shavin did was
good
decent justified or non-jailable no one
okay but
to to draw a direct line between bull
connor and derek chalvin without any
evidence whatsoever
or to pretend that was commonplace and
and
not only commonplace but enshrined in
jim crow law
is similar in any way to what happened
with derek chavin is utterly
patently crazy okay but obama gets away
with this kind of stuff because the
media have decided for years that they
are simply going to
carry around drool cups for the guy it's
amazing
it's amazing then obama called the
philip
he went after the senate filibuster
again this is at a memorial for a man
who just died
and spends his life attempting to unify
the nation around racial issues
here's barack obama saying that the
senate filibuster is a jim crow holdover
which is pretty incredible because i'm
old enough to remember when barack obama
senator barack obama
filibustered samuel alito for the
supreme court tried to filibuster him
i'm old enough to remember when
democrats like five seconds ago
filibustered senator tim scott's police
reform bill
was that a jim crow vestige
by essentially saying that the
filibuster is racist this does
give the lie to the idea that democrats
don't want to tear down the system now
in a bit we're going to get to donald
trump
saying something about delaying
elections that really does tear away at
the roots of the democracy but
to pretend that democrats are not doing
the same thing and haven't been doing
the same thing for a long time
is to cut against all available evidence
here's barack obama suggesting that the
senate filibuster
is a tool of jim crow despite the fact
that he himself used the filibuster when
he was in the senate and democrats have
been very fond of the filibuster they
were using it against george w bush's
judicial nominees
here's here's barack obama again
demagoguing donald trump is president
because
everybody decided that barack obama
speaking this way
was completely apolitical here he was
calling the filibuster jim crow
once we pass the john lewis voting
rights act
we should keep marching by guaranteeing
that every american citizen has equal
representation
in our government including the american
citizens who live in washington dc
and in puerto rico and if all this takes
eliminating the filibuster
another jim crow relic in order to
secure the god-given rights of every
american
then that's what we should do okay this
is such cynical i'm sorry it is
it's incredibly cynical it's
unbelievably cynical this is a man who's
happy to use the filibuster when it was
in his own benefit
and who's anti-filibuster when it's not
his benefit and this is something i do
talk about in my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps one of the
goals of the constitution and many of
the senate procedures
is to create checks and balances why
because america's rights
are preserved through checks and
balances the idea is that a government
that is unable to stomp on those rights
at will
will not be able to stomp on those
rights it will the idea is that when you
set up these checks and balances it
prevents
a pure majority the tyranny of the mob
the tyranny of the majority from
stomping on the rights of a minority
and for all the people who are like well
yeah but you know in in the south
a pure majority was able to stomp on the
rights of the minority
that's exactly the point the point is
there should have been more checks and
balances
the federal government should have
stepped in and stopped the trampling of
rights
in the states the filibuster is simply a
tool to prevent the trampling of
minority rights by majorities that is
one of the goals of the filibuster now
it doesn't mean
there aren't times when the filibuster
can't be used for nefarious purposes the
civil rights act was filibustered by
strom thurmond
but it is also true that there are many
procedures that are written into the
constitution with the direct intent
of making sure that there has to be a
broad spectrum support for particular
policy before it goes into law
one of the points of the filibuster is
to create exactly
the sorts of checks and balances on pure
majoritarianism that allow for the
for the destruction of individual
american rights
and here is the point when it comes to
democrats very often when they talk
about institutions they don't care about
the institutions the institutions are
either a barrier or a weapon
so the filibuster is sometimes weapon
that's when it's good and then when it's
not good then they get rid of it
barack obama within five minutes will be
arguing that the senate itself should be
done away with because the senate as it
turns out
is actually non-representational right
having two senators for each state
two for wyoming and two for california
when the population of wyoming is seven
people and the population of
california's 40 million people that's
unrepresentative it's undemocratic
so democrats will stomp in favor of the
senate when they control
it and they want to add senators from
puerto rico and washington dc
and then they'll stump against the
senate when they don't control it
they'll stump in favor of the filibuster
when they can use it in their favor
and they will stump against the
filibuster when it is when it is wrong
which
suggests that they don't care about the
institutions of government one iota it's
not about the institutions of government
it's about what they can use the
government to do to you
so this kind of demagoguery barack obama
was an awful president and
he's an awful ex-president and then
obama continued along these lines we'll
get to more of barack obama demagoguing
at the at the memorial service for john
lewis in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you
believe in individual liberty and
personal responsibility you believe in
the second amendment one of the things
that many people are after right now is
the second amendment the destruction
of the second amendment they believe
that the second amendment is a barrier
to the goals of the federal government
they believe that individuals
who are responsible owning guns is
somehow a threat to public safety which
is obviously untrue
the founders enshrined rights in the
constitution and they recognize that the
people needed to be armed in order to
protect
themselves against the tyranny of
government and yes against crime
as well the people at bravo company mfg
support the right of responsible
private individuals to have the access
and ability to employ the same tools as
civilian law enforcement as a means of
defending ourselves our loved ones our
communities and our freedoms
should a threatening situation ever
arise and given the fact that so many in
law enforcement
have now been barred from protecting you
and your property this becomes more
vital than ever
bcm assumes that when a rifle leaves
their shop it could be used in a life or
death situation
by a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas so quality
is of utmost value to them
every component of a bcm rifle is
hand-assembled and tested by americans
as an american you have the luxury of
living in a free society where it can
improve your life through education
religious exploration and the open
exchange of ideas every american
is responsible to question debate
confront issues that affect our lives if
and when your life and liberty ever come
under
serious governmental threat or any other
threat firearms a means to preserve the
lives and liberties of ourselves and
others the founding fathers understood
this they understood this clearly so do
the folks over at bcm
to learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to
bravocompanymfg.com you can discover
more about their products
special offers upcoming news that's
bravocompanymfg.com
or check them out at youtube.com
bravocompanyusa that's youtube.com
bravo company usa okay so president
obama didn't just stop by calling for
the overthrow of the filibuster and
suggesting that today's police and
federal agents
are in league with george wallace and
bill connor he then suggested that there
is a wide variety of attempts to stop
the vote again there is no evidence of
this the idea of widespread voter
suppression in the united states is
nonsense
it is nonsense it's nonsense when donald
trump says it it is nonsense when barack
obama says it it is nonsense
the black population of the united
states thank god votes in heavy numbers
and in the last several election cycles
and certainly when barack obama was
elected in both 2008 and 2012
outvoted their share of the population
but barack obama is fully
on board with the stacey abrams lie that
black people are systematically being
prevented from the vote which is it is a
lie there is no evidence that this is
the case
that there are people out there who are
like black people shouldn't vote here is
barack obama's suggesting
that some people's like some people's
like but i shouldn't go so political
at a memorial but guess what standards
don't apply to me
i'm gonna say whenever i please i'm just
gonna make crap up let's go
there are those in power who are doing
their darndest
to discourage people from voting
by closing polling locations and
targeting minorities
and students with restrictive id laws
and attacking our voting rights with
surgical precision
now i know this is a celebration of
john's life
[Applause]
there are some who might say
we shouldn't dwell on such things
but that's why i'm talking about it oh
well you know there are some
it's like that stopping black people
from voting ain't no problem but i'm
going to talk about it anyway
no one's saying you can't talk about it
but you are lying
the the notion that black people in
america are being systematically
deprived of the vote is just not true it
is not true
okay show me the evidence and don't give
me voter id
okay voter id is not attempt to stop
people from voting
voter id is a fine idea approved by by
the way
in every poll a majority of nearly every
demographic group including black folks
as far as i'm aware
but barack obama is this this is how you
got donald trump you guys want to know
how you got donald trump you gaslight
the entire american population
he suggested over and over that this man
was the epitome of class
that he was above politics that he was
some sort of godlike figure
from on high he is just a a typical
chicago-style machine politician he
always was
and here he was using a memorial service
for a man whose politics i disagreed
with in many ways but who did do
incredible good for the united states
and instead of just paying tribute to
him in a classy way the way george w
bush did barack obama got up there and
suggested that america is living
with the vestiges of jim crow and bull
connor
he suggested that him that america is
dominated by neo-segregationists
and people attempting to stop black
people from voting he was a deeply
divisive president the divisions on race
in this country did not start with
donald trump look back at the polls
divisions on race in this country
began in 2009 with barack obama getting
overtly overtly racially political you
can look at the polls
hopes for racial reconciliation in this
country were never higher than when
barack obama was elected and within two
years of his election they had
completely cratered
and they continued to crater today
it was an honestly it was an ugly
spectacle it was an ugly spectacle
i'm old enough to remember when barack
obama went out there during the ferguson
rioting and said people don't make up
things like this
he was talking about the michael brown
shooting the michael brown shooting by
the way was a good shoot
in fact it turns out that after another
review
of the michael brown shooting by officer
darren wilson it turns out
five years after the six years after the
case the case has been dismissed again
according to the daily wire today amanda
presley giacomo reporting st louis
county prosecuting attorney wesley bell
announced on thursday he will not be
bringing charges against former ferguson
police department officer darren wilson
who fatally shot michael brown 18 back
in 2014.
during a thursday press conference bell
announced the news by prefacing it as
quote one of the most difficult things
i've had to do noting that his heart
breaks for the browns
the question for the office was a simple
one could prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that when darren wilson shot
michael brown he committed murder or
manslaughter under missouri law bell
asked after an independent and in-depth
review of the evidence we cannot prove
that he did he by the way is the
county's first
black prosecutor he reopened and
reopened the case after taking office
one of the reasons he gained office is
because of disapproval for no case
against darren wilson in the first place
and then he looked at the evidence and
he said sorry we can't actually make
a case bell said his office conducted a
five-month review of witness statements
forensic reports
and other evidence the ap noted adding
his investigations it's not exonerate
darren wilson by the way it's not the
way the criminal justice process works
if you are not convicted that does not
mean you are not ex
that does not mean that you are
exonerated there is no exonerated
standard in criminal law they're just
not prosecuted
so you also don't get declared not
exonerated that's not the way this works
bell said i know this is not the result
they were looking for and that their
pain will continue
forever jim talley wilson's attorney
noted bill's review had the same
conclusion
as bell's predecessor a grand jury and
the usdoj that was obama's doj by the
way there was no crime
the obama justice department at the time
pointed out
that there was no crime but doesn't
matter democrats have continued to lie
about the michael brown shooting and use
it as the basis
for a political campaign to suggest that
america and his police officers are
deeply racist
now as we will see the exploitation of
prominent people's death was not
relegated to john lewis yesterday it
also extended over to
herman cain the 74 year old former
republican candidate for president
in 2012 the first black republican ever
to lead presidential polling in 2012
he passed away he passed away from covet
and that led the
media to jump on his death and use it
for their own political purposes this is
about as ugly as it gets guys it
really is ugly between the demagoguery
of barack obama over john lewis's death
and the attempts to link george wallace
with today's federal law enforcement
protecting federal buildings from
rioters and looters
and the media jumping on herman cain's
death to blame president trump
this is hideous stuff it really is and
it really does disintegrate the country
it just rules of basic decency
completely out the window we'll get some
more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that computer systems and
cars are the norm from electronically
controlled transmissions
the touchscreen displays to dozens of
sensors but you don't know how to fix
any of that stuff what are you a car
expert
so when something breaks it could cost a
fortune now is not the time for
expensive repairs that is why i
have car shield and you should as well
car shield has affordable protection
plans that can save you thousands for a
covered repair
including computers gps electronics and
more the people at car shield understand
payment flexibility is an absolute must
monthly plans can be customized to your
needs with rates as low as 99 bucks a
month
no long-term contracts or commitments
car shield will give you options others
won't you get to choose your favorite
mechanic or dealership to do the work
car shield takes care of the rest they
also offer complimentary 24 7 roadside
assistance and a rental car while yours
is being fixed for as low as 99 bucks a
month you can protect yourself from
surprises and save thousands for a
covered repair call 800
car 6000 mention code ben or visit
carshield.com and use codebend to save
that is carshield.com use codeben a
deductible
may apply again protect yourself from
the expenses attached
to fixing your car car call 800
car 6000 mention code ben or go to
carshield.com use codebend to save
10 solid deal on protecting yourself
from the payments
that come with having a car that breaks
down go check them out 800 car 6000
mentioned codeben
car shield.com could ben save 10 okay so
when it comes to public deaths the the
insanity is not relegated to the
memorial for john lewis it extended over
to herman cain
chris cuomo who is just terrible i mean
just a terrible terrible quote-unquote
reporter
not an apparently not a particularly
good person either and i say that
advisedly
maybe he's a nice guy i really don't
have an idea but it seems kind of gross
that when herman caden dies of covid
your first move is
let me yell at president trump about it
like that
first of all herman cain had agency
second of all
herman cain's life story was not him
dying of covid herman king's life story
was growing up in segregated atlanta
and becoming president of a federal
reserve bank and running papa john's
and getting a degree while serving in
the us navy herman cain had a long and
rich life
and now his death has been reduced to he
died of covetous trump's fault by the
media
which is pretty disgusting it truly is
here was chris cuomo yesterday
saying that it's trump's fault that
herman cain is dead despite the fact
there's no evidence that kane actually
obtained the virus at trump's rally in
tulsa and
herman cain happened to be a an
individual with the agency of his own
here was chris cuomo blaming trump
former presidential candidate
herman cain yes he supported the
president the president says he was a
good friend of his
we wish his family well and we wish that
he rest in peace
and i wish that this president have no
peace
until he thinks about what he's exposing
people to he didn't even
mention that mr cain was at
his rally among the maskless masses
right before he was diagnosed
now maybe he didn't get it there sure as
hell didn't help
sure as hell didn't help how the hell do
you know anything you don't know
anything
is the answer by the way it wasn't uh
papa john's obviously uh it was a
godfather's pizza in any case
first of all who the hell is chris clone
to talk about this chris cuomo who went
on air every single night
and massaged his brother's ass on air as
his brother presided over the largest
death toll in america
from covet 19. chris cuomo who every
night was talking about the glories of
public rallies in which people were not
wearing masks and had not one thing to
say
about pandemic preparedness or pandemic
protection while these massive
rallies on social justice warrior
messaging took place in the streets
chris cuomo who spent his evenings
showing up
on national tv with giant nasal swabs
to make fun of his brother's nose size
chris cuomo who
ditched his own quarantine in order to
apparently go to his second house
while he had coveted that guy is gonna
lecture trump about herman cain
again without any evidence that that
kane picked this thing up at the trump
rally
by the way i i do have a question
everybody's saying well this is because
you know it's because herman cain didn't
wear mask
my understanding is that the masks don't
protect you they protect everybody else
isn't that the math of the masks
we've been told that routinely that the
only masks that protect you
are the n95 respirators that are used in
hospitals and if you're wearing a
surgical mask it protects everybody else
it doesn't protect you so even if you've
been wearing a mask that wouldn't have
protected him from getting it presumably
right that is what we have been told
unless i'm getting that very very wrong
and by the way it's not a case against
mask wearing
but again the the media's attempt to
twist this into a story of trumpian evil
and to reduce herman cain's life to his
death is really disgusting
reuters did the same thing so reuters
had a headline about herman cain here
was their headline
about again a man who at one point led
the 2012 republican presidential race
a man who served on the federal reserve
board of chairs a man who
spent his entire life becoming a success
in the united states as a black man in
america growing up
in a segregated america in atlanta here
is how reuters summed up herman cain's
life
quote herman cain a former republican
presidential candidate and supporter of
president trump who refused to wear a
mask during the coronavirus pandemic has
died after contracting covet 19.
he got a dunk on the guy because he
didn't wear a mask it seems to me that
so much of the focus on mask wearing
listen again i think you should wear a
mask i've been saying consistently for
months
as soon as the conventional wisdom
turned i've been saying what's the harm
where the mask
it can't hurt and that's what i've been
saying for months okay so this is not a
diatribe against mask wearing what i'm
about to say
but it seems to me that many of the
people who are focused in on dunking on
people who die after quote unquote not
wearing masks what they're really
attempting to do
is create in their own minds a
protective shield by which they say okay
well if i do
all of the approved things then for sure
i won't die for sure i'll be okay
but if i wear the mask and if i if i pay
attention to what the media tell me
then i i won't die then i'll be okay and
the answer is
there's no evidence that that's the case
okay the answer is i'm sure there are
many people who have died
who have been pretty careful about this
stuff in fact there are stories of
people who have been pretty careful
about this stuff we're dying
it's there's a certain amount of
dissociation that is going on and listen
i understand it i get it i do the same
thing i'm a human being
everybody does whenever somebody dies
the first question you ask is how
and then if they did something of which
you don't approve oh well at least it
won't happen to me
okay but herman cain's life story is not
about how he died it's about how he
lived
and the attempt to reduce him to his
death method so that you can
snack around donald trump on mask
scoring by the way while donald trump is
going out and now preaching that
everybody should wear masks
is pretty gross and this was the
predominant sentiment by the way online
yesterday
leftists blaming herman cain for his own
death and suggesting that donald trump
is responsible for his own death
tony poznanski tweeted out
there's another one he's blue check
marked lefties he tweeted out
i feel bad for him and cain and his
family but i don't feel bad for his
selfishness
his mocking of a deadly disease nor
convincing others is safe to go massless
i refuse to have sympathy for those who
put my family in danger wear an mf
mask okay i wonder what he has to say
about denmark or netherlands where they
have refused to mandate mass scoring
because they say that the evidence on it
is pretty scanty which by the way it
kind of is that doesn't mean you
shouldn't wear a mask it doesn't mean
you shouldn't be careful but to pretend
that the evidence is absolutely clear
neglects the fact that there are plenty
of countries where they are not
mandating mass scoring because
the evidence is not exactly clear at
this point
over and over and over again members of
the media were
using herman cain's death to dunk on the
man which is just really kind of
disgusting
anna navarro who's become just a bleep
show she tweeted out herman cain thought
coved was a hoax
scoffed at wearing a mask died of cove
that is not true there's a post on
herman cain's website today from his
staff pointing out that he has started
every podcast recently
with the note that everybody should wash
your hands a lot and yes that when
you're in public you should wear a mask
bill montgomery she says bill montgomery
co-founder of pro-trump turning point
usa scoffed at virus died of covet
representative gomer refused to wear a
mask has coveted see a pattern kova
doesn't care about partisanship
okay i i don't remember anna navarro
tweeting the same thing about mass
rallies in the streets where people were
not wearing their masks
but you know so long as you can dunk on
people then you can feel good about
yourself so really well done
all around well done just the country's
getting better moment by moment can you
feel it
really good stuff in just a second we're
going to get to the nba making the
country better
one weird jersey name at a time we'll
get to that momentarily first
let's talk about something nice i know i
know the news has been so annoying and
so bad lately
but let's talk about something nice you
can do for yourself do for your family
i'm talking about a beautiful portrait
of you
and your family done by a professional
artist done to spec
it's really great and it's not going to
cost you a fortune you should go out and
you should try
paintyourlife.com you can choose from a
team of world-class artists and work
with them
until every detail is perfect their
user-friendly platform lets you order a
custom-made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes you can send any
picture yourself your kids family a
special place cherished pet
or you can combine photos into one
painting it makes a perfect birthday
anniversary or wedding gift
it's meaningful it's personal it can be
cherished forever
at paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed and right
now as a limited time offer you get 20
off your painting that is correct 20 off
and free shipping to get the special
offer text the word ben
to 64 000 text ben to 64 000 again text
ben
to 64 thousand paint your life celebrate
the moments that matter most get 20
off and free shipping when you text ben
to 64 000 and get started it really is
fantastic i have a portrait of my family
hanging above our mantle at home from
paint your life it is one of my favorite
things
in the house in fact i have to get
another one because we have a new baby
she's the cutest person in the entire
world oh my god she's just spectacular
it's sad to me that the internet is such
a garbage place otherwise
you would be forced to agree that my
baby is in fact the cutest person but i
will know that because i will have a
painting from paint your life on my
mantel
of my baby so cute squishy baby
text ben's a 64 000 and check out paint
your life right now
for the 20 discount okay in just a
second we're gonna get to the nba
making the country better one jersey at
a time
we'll get to that momentarily first it
is that glorious time of the week when i
give a shout out to a daily wire member
today it's gop josh on twitter who not
only has quality
fashion sense but also understands the
importance of nourishing the mind
as well as the body in the picture josh
is holding the world's most elite
beverage vessel in one hand
and a copy of my new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps in the other
while sporting american flag sunglasses
an american eagle t-shirt and a keep
america
great hat the caption reads ben shapiro
great book great beverage vessel hashtag
leftist year's tumblr user
wise beyond your years thanks for the
shout out i hope you're enjoying the
book
i know you are because it's a great book
speaking of interesting news the spacex
caps will be landing this sunday august
2nd
it is the first time spacex will have
completed a successfully crewed missions
the iss and
the first time in over a decade that
accrued spaceship was launched from the
united states
it's a pretty awesome deal we will be
live streaming it across youtube at
facebook and dailywire.com
featuring a special all-access live
discussion with daily wear god king
jeremy boring who's obsessed with this
kind of stuff
all access members can join the chat and
talk to jeremy during the live stream of
the mission
and then stick around afterward for a
live stream q a you can watch him answer
your questions in real time so don't
miss out
join all access at dailywire.com shapiro
get 20
off with code access that's
dailywear.com 20
off with code access also reminder my
new book how to destroy america in three
easy steps is available right now it is
number two
on every bestseller chart except for the
new york times number three get your
copy at amazon or barnesandnoble.com if
you like the book please hop in and
leave a five star review it keeps it
higher on the chart so more people see
it
enjoy you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
well at least if we're gonna live in the
most garbage timeline we have
distractions like the nba right i mean
at least we can
enjoy sports together until they decide
to politicize everything about sports
and make them stupid so i'm not saying
you can't enjoy basketball you can
but it does take a little bit of
overlooking when they decide that social
justice warrior messaging
is going to be just poured into
just i mean up to the brim into the nba
into the mlb into the nfl apparently the
end zones in the nfl are going to have
things like equality and stand for
justice like on the end zones now
it's great i mean honestly what they
what they really should just do
is they should just label these are all
in-kind contributions to the democratic
party because let's be frank about this
all the slogan airing here is designed
to back up a particular narrative about
america is systemically racist that the
democratic party preaches
right we are we are engaged right now in
again what what linguists call semantic
overload
there's nothing wrong with the principle
of equality before the law all right
that is a very good principle there's
nothing wrong
with the principle of peace right all of
these things are good but let's be real
about this when people say black lives
matter and they put it on the side of a
basketball court what they do not mean
is that black lives matter the same as
white lives and all lives matter that's
not what they mean
they do because that's eminently obvious
what they mean is that america's
systemically racist right that is the
semantic overload point
because if you say to them i agree black
lives matter and also america is not
systemically racist
then they will respond and say then you
don't agree black lives matter which
means that you are just using
a semantically overloaded term so that
you can avoid saying what you actually
mean because what you actually mean is a
lot more unpopular than what you're
saying
right that that is what is happening
right here right now every single person
agrees in america that black lives
matter because you'd be an awful human
being not to agree that black lives
matter but that is not what black lives
matter advocates mean when they say
black lives matter what they actually
mean is that police are evil and that
america's systemically racist
and that all inequality is a result of
systematic inequity right that's what
they actually mean so the nba has
decided to go full bore on this
so last night they had the relaunched
nba inside the bubble
and all the players knelt for the
national anthem so now everybody's
kaepernicking
because obviously america's a terrible
horrible place where you get to earn
millions of dollars for playing
a child's game in front of adoring
audiences
and americans care so little about black
lives that they are they are more than
happy
to watch basketball players paid
millions of dollars to dunk a basketball
very very cruel country this is deeply
cruel terrible country in which
americans obviously don't agree that
black lives matter which is why
we spend tens of millions of dollars
watching games and patronizing products
that are advertised by these
spokespeople
and the american flag is responsible the
american flag is bad for the revisionist
historians who suggest that kneeling for
the national anthem by the way is a sign
of respect
for the flag it was never meant as a
sign of respect for the
for the flag it was meant as a sign of
disrespect for the flag
it was meant that way it was meant
originally as a as a signifier that
america is systemically racist and the
flag represents that systemic racism
okay again you can do like i'm at least
the mlb
knelt before the national anthem but
kneeling for the national anthem is
saying that the national
anthem is not true and that the flag is
not true so the nba led off with this
which of course makes it harder to watch
the game because
again no one is watching basketball to
hear the social justice warrior
messaging but they decided to get even
more obvious about it they did this
routine where they basically went full
xfl if you remember the xfl people were
putting
names on their jerseys like he hate me
those nicknames on their jersey he hate
me was the most famous one
well yesterday the nba had players
wearing
words on their jerseys like slogans on
their jerseys and it seems to me they
should just put biden 2020
on their jerseys if this is what they
really think or america sucks on their
jerseys if that's what they really think
instead you have the bizarre picture
of players throwing up alley oops well
like if you don't know the players you
literally have no idea who is playing
right now like the purpose of the name
on the back of the jersey
used to be to identify the players so
instead
you had equality throwing an alley for
peace i'm not kidding metal world peace
was really ahead of his time
amanda had a world be free a man ahead
of his time
here is actually like that's actually
what happened i mean i don't even know
how the announcers announced this
and they know the names of the players
but if you didn't right if you're just
watching this thing it's like
and coming up the court is equality here
comes equality running up the court
throws up an alley up to peace and
there's peace slamming at home
over say their names
that's literally how look yesterday that
would be the sound
that you'd hear down under strong finish
zion williamson on a special delivery
equality throwing it up to peace
he's got posterize right here he's got
dunked zion just spins
exciting exciting stuff so equality
throws it up for peace peace dunks over
peace
good good stuff everybody um
yeah i i noticed free hong kong was
benched so uh stop the nba's chinese
talent sweatshop
that person never made it to the court
so that's that's too bad charles barkley
got a lot of flack yesterday because
charles barkley who may be the only sane
person left dealing with the nba he said
by the way if you don't kneel you're not
a bad person
and everybody's like yes you are you're
a bad person if you don't kneel we've
reached the point
where that which is not barred is
mandatory
where it it's not that remember we
started off with like
should colin kaepernick be allowed to
kneel and most people are like i think
it's a bad idea but like i don't think
you should be banned from from kneeling
like i think i think it's kind of a
garbagey thing to do but i don't think
you should be bad and now it's mandatory
you're a bad person who doesn't care
about black people if you don't kneel
for the national anthem
a national anthem that represents a
country that has seen more racial
progress than any other country in human
history
and in which the richest black people on
planet earth live
by average income okay but but
apparently charles barkley's a bad guy
for saying that if you don't kneel
you're not a bad person like this is how
far we have come
my thing is listen the national anthem
mean different things to different
people
i'm glad these guys are all unified but
the people if people don't kneel
they're not a bad person i want to make
that perfectly clear
i'm glad they had unity but if we have a
guy who doesn't want to kneel because
the answer means something to him
he should not okay and everybody came
down on barclay how dare he say that
he's not woke enough charles barkley
yeah
all right well this this is the way the
culture is moving
by by the way speaking of the way the
culture is moving i have to read you the
best headline of the day it is from cnn
on a slightly different topic you ready
for this headline from cnn this is
spectacular they brought out this
morning quote
individuals of the cervix are now
recommended to start cervical cancer
screenings at 25
and continue through age 65 with hpv
testing every five years
as the preferred method of testing
according to a new guideline released by
the american cancer society
you notice something wrong with that
particular headline individuals with a
cervix
are recommended to start cervical cancer
screenings you know what we call
individuals of the cervix in the real
world we call them women
remember that time when cnn said an
apple is not a banana banana's not an
apple
now apparently a banana can have an
apple which is really exciting stuff
individuals with a cervix do you sir
take this individual with the cervix to
be your lawfully wedded wife
how romantic wokeness has proceeded so
far that women have been completely
erased
they don't even exist anymore
individuals with the cervix
individuals of the cervix just fantastic
fantastic stuff
now here's the thing there will be a
backlash to this in the backlash i think
will come in the form of reasonable
people just saying you know what no
i'm not kneeling for the national anthem
nor do i frankly feel like patronizing
basketball games where i'm lectured
about how america's systemically racist
by people who are earning millions and
millions of dollars to call america
systemically racist
uh honestly the best thing that happened
yesterday is maybe the only good thing
that happened yesterday was trader joe's
said you know what
we're not changing our labels remember a
few days ago there's a big story about
people petitioning
saying that trader jose's like guacamole
was racist well trader joe's put out a
statement they're like nope
nope they said a few weeks ago an online
petition was
launched calling on us to quote remove
racist packaging from our products
following where inaccurate reports that
the petition prompted us to take action
we want to be clear we disagree that any
of these labels are racist
we do not make decisions based on
petitions thank you
thank you it's about damn time somebody
said this
they said we make decisions based on
what customers purchased as well as the
feedback we receive
from our customers and crew members if
we feel there's need for change we do
not hesitate to take action
decades ago our buying team started
using product names like trader giattos
trader jose
trader mings etc we thought then and
still do that this naming of products
could be fun and show appreciation for
other cultures
for example we named our mexican beer
trader jose premium
and a couple guacamole products are
called avocado's number in a kitschy
reference to a mathematical theory
these products have been really popular
with our customers including some
budding mathematicians
recently we have heard from many
customers reaffirming these name
variations are largely viewed in exactly
the way they were intended as an attempt
to have fun with our product marketing
we'll continue our ongoing evaluation
and those products that resonate with
our customers and sell well
will remain on our shelves good for
trader joe's guess what there's not
going to be an end to this
there really is not because there
the the social justice warrior insanity
it doesn't end
at any point there's no limiting
principle to it which is why you're
seeing it
this one i love you're seeing beyonce
come under fire there's a new
documentary it's like it's not really a
documentary it's sort of like a
a movie that is called black is king for
disney plus that is produced by beyonce
now first of all let me just point out
that if disney plus launched a uh
launched a program called white is king
it would be the end of the world
right it would be the end of the world
they launched a program called black is
king and everybody's like okay totally
fine
in any case black is king is based on
the lion king which is i mean first of
all isn't that cultural appropriation
like it's based on lion king
the music for lion king was originally
written by two white guys elton john and
tim rice and the story of lion king is
based on william shakespeare's hamlet
who happened to be a white guy so
seems like a little cultural
appropriation now beyonce's under a
little bit of fire
because it turns out that beyonce is not
in fact african and for her to
culturally appropriate african culture
is sort of a problem for some people on
the left not kidding there are articles
on this today
people defending beyonce saying she's
allowed to do it because she's
disconnected from her history but her
disconnection from her own history is
because of
white intervention over slavery and all
this the fact that it's even a
controversy is bizarre
she's paying tribute to africa there's
nothing wrong with that but the fact
that it's a controversy shows how stupid
everything is
in fact things are so stupid that now
portland's wall of moms
is falling apart portland's wild not
remember these are the woke white ladies
who are supposedly protecting
peaceful protesters who are actually
vicious rioters and looters from the
predations of federal police officers
attempting to stop
violations of law now the wall of moms
is falling apart why
because they were too white not kidding
according to oregon live
portland's wall of moms a group formed
in recent weeks and quickly recognized
as a staple of nightly downtown protests
was accused publicly wednesday of
anti-blackness by leaders of an existing
black-led community group wall of moms
whose members said they aimed to support
and protect
other black lives matter protesters near
the fence in front of the federal
courthouse
announced friday that its white
leadership had rescinded their positions
to allow women of color to be in charge
so the wall of moms fell apart because
they weren't black enough
new leaders announced friday include
teresa rayford executive director of
don't shoot portland
demetria hester and danielle james less
than a week later don't shoot portland
took to instagram to urge people against
supporting
the wall of moms saying it was no longer
working with the mom's group
because after leaving vulnerable black
women downtown after marching failing to
support those on the ground that put
trust in them while of mom's leadership
also found time to make three
registrations
through oregon's secretary of state this
was done without the knowledge of the
black
leadership that wall of moms was
claiming to implement the lies are
finally clear
we are sad but ultimately not surprised
that anti-blackness showed its ugly face
with wall of moms good times they
weren't woke enough
because guess what you're never woke
enough ever ever ever
there is no the wokeness never ends it
just there's no limitations
to the wokeness now if you're thinking
to yourself you know all of this seems
like pretty solid ground for president
trump to campaign
and so he got the democrats seeking to
undermine fundamental institutions of
american
republicanism and checks and balances
like filibusters you have democrats
seeking to prop up rioting and looting
you have a system so woke that the wall
of moms is not woke enough
you have every major cultural
institution pushing social justice
warrior messaging about how america's
systemically evil wouldn't that be some
pretty fertile ground for trump to
campaign
uh well lest you forget donald trump is
busy distracting us all with absolute
utter
insane stupidity so i remember that
yesterday president trump floated the
idea of postponing the election which
is fundamentally unconstitutional you
cannot do that the
s the election is set as the first as
the first weekend
in november right it has been set that
way by the constitution of the united
states for
well over 150 years the president
doesn't have that kind of power
now yesterday i kind of shrugged it off
a little bit because trump says a lot of
crap and it's true he does say a lot of
crap and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
pretend i take trump particularly
seriously
as a person i don't i've never taken
trump particularly seriously
as a person because i think if you do
then you're doing it wrong
frankly that does not justify his
activity in undermining fundamental
faith in american democracy by saying
that the vote is going to be so
corrupted that we should postpone the
election
right that is a tactic that democrats
have been using stacey abrams has been
using it
i mean frankly barack obama did it when
he suggested that there's been
widespread voter suppression against
black americans
it doesn't make it better when trump
does it and
trump really opened the door to
everybody clocking him it's political
malpractice and
it's unconstitutional unreasonable
foolish
and wrong for the president of the
united states to threaten delaying the
election
it really justifies a lot of the
complaints about trump that are there
have
i i'm old enough to remember when i was
defending trump against charges he was
going to say stuff like this and then he
went ahead and said stuff like this
and that left running room for the left
so chuck schumer said not the election's
going to be november 3rd and of course
he is correct about those
once again all he wants to do is divert
from his abject failure in the corona
virus crisis he says oh well maybe we
won't have an election
that's up to the senate in the house mr
president president trump
the election will be on november in
november
on november third and you will not
change it
she's right about this diverting
attention president trump
that's what you've done okay well in any
case the rest of it is irrelevant but
that
he's not wrong the election will take
place at this point now the question is
whether you take trump
with a grain of salt because he's
fundamentally an unserious human being
which is what i've thought for a very
long time that has not wavered for years
or whether you take it super duper
seriously if you take it seriously it's
a fascist threat if barack obama said
i'm delaying the election
everybody on the right would completely
go nuts the reason i don't take trump as
seriously as obama is because i don't
think that trump is as serious a person
as obama i think he mouths off my proof
for the fact that he just mouths off and
says crap is that he mouths off and says
crap
he himself said this yesterday he came
out and said glad i was able to get the
very dishonest lamestream media to
finally start talking
about the risks to our democracy from
dangerous universal mail and voting
not absentee voting which i totally
support so he came out and he said oh
yeah yeah by the way when i was saying
delayed the election it was really just
a misdirect tactic so people would talk
about melon voting which
god said okay so why not just say melon
voting is bad
it is bad there are reports about how
bad it is you don't have to do that you
have to make a fistic threat to delay
the election
it's like he deliberately wants to blow
the election i don't know what else to
take away from from this kind of idiocy
i really do not the democrats all they
had to do is not be nuts they are nuts
and trump could still lose the election
because he's acting like this and you
know what if he acts like this frankly
it's on him
alrighty well we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content
otherwise we'll be here on monday in the
meantime go pick up a copy of my brand
new book how to destroy america in three
easy steps that describes everything
that is going on including the campaign
against the filibuster now being pursued
by democrats so go check that out it is
number three on the new york times
bestowals number two
on the wall street journal publishers
weekly amazon bestseller-less make it
number one by going to
amazon and picking up a copy today i am
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pavel
wydowsky
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen